and now i see this check this out
because we're talking about
crypto and all that stuff you know what
35
of all u.s dollars that have ever been
printed were printed in the last
10 months i shared that one check it out
first came out
you got to show the graphic
so i saw this post some lefties were
posting about it on facebook
and they're and they're showing this
graph from uh f
it's fred and it's economic research
federal reserve bank of st
louis and we can see 35
of all u.s dollars dude this is a huge
warning sign
uh to diversify out of the u.s dollar
right now so here's what the lefties
were talking about
someone posted this on facebook saying
y'all are talking about universal
healthcare this and this here's what i'm
worried about
and someone responded with we can
deficit spend forever
and why would you be worried about that
because a lot of lefties like i think
aoc
even mentioned this well just deficits
spend into massive debt forever
and then someone mentioned that the guy
who posted it was like i'm worried about
weimar germany
and then linked to a photo of people
shoveling german marks into a gutter
so i started reading about it i don't
think it's the exact same thing
but because there was a desperate need
to pay back
the the it was reparations from world
war one they just kept printing money
to try and keep spending it and paying
back you know to keep the machine going
essentially
it's not identical but right now all
this money is being printed because
nothing's being produced
now that's a serious problem nothing is
being produced
so they give people money to buy what's
remaining
that means the things i remember earlier
in the year
when everyone's like oh man you know
what happens now with with the lockdowns
and everything
and what did i do i went to the store
every so often and i bought a normal
supply of groceries we didn't go crazy
we didn't run to the store and and buy
like 10 shopping carts of beans
we did buy you know like like 20 cans of
beans and i was like we'll get some
beans put them in the pantry right
and then i ordered these emergency food
things why the things you see on the
shelf right now
were made a while ago and so when you
start seeing
no one working when the restaurants are
now shut down in new york if that means
a lot of things are going to happen for
one
we're not insulated we are to a certain
degree on shows like this
people who make digital content are
going to lose tons of money
when they shut down indoor dining
because small businesses and restaurants
will stop spending money on ads to get
customers
more importantly when people aren't
going to work they aren't making things
so what's going to happen eventually is
going to have a you're going to have a
ridiculous amount of money from from the
u.s from the us government being printed
like crazy
and nothing to buy with it so what
happens you're going to have big old
stacks of dollars and you're going to be
like oh
can't buy anything with it what do i
need it for and if you wait too long the
prices of stuff is gonna skyrocket
it's already up 20 years check this out
i'm talking about check this out i rock
it
i i put in my amazon shopping cart a
galaxy tablet
i was like i could use a tablet so you
know around the house i could be looking
at news and doing stuff
and then i forgot about it i got an
alert when i went to amazon the other
day and it said price change from 500 to
650.
yeah yeah for the same thing most goods
are going up dramatically that's modest
especially raw
goods especially things that are used to
produce other goods they're becoming
very limited in supply
and it's absolutely terrifying the
bigger economic ramifications that are
coming our way
not only because of the lockdown but
because of the federal reserve
you said if they start printing money
like crazy they already are
most of that money 35 yeah think about
how
so when i was on the show a couple weeks
ago the first time i told you
what was it 25 percent i forgot the
exact 103.6 yeah 23.6 that number has
already risen it's going to continue
to rise and most of that money is
literally going towards companies like
blackrock one of the biggest asset
owning companies in the entire world
that is literally in the chinese stock
market so we are literally
giving socialism to the super rich right
now
and they're transferring that money to
the chinese stock market of all places
yes take a look at this
from the street and this is from october
15th
23.6 of all u.s dollars were created in
the last
year in the last 23.6 where are we at
now
well according to a bunch of posts that
are going around i don't know if that's
the
exact correct number but they say 35.
let's just assume that's correct
from october two months later we went
from 23.6 to 35
12 more points up they are cranking out
dollars they're spinning that money
machine like crazy
now some people have said that there's
going to be
rapid deflation because there's nothing
to buy
so but i honestly i don't know if that
makes a whole new said that
there's just been posts on the internet
saying no no we're facing what's the
logic i guess
the logic is if there's nothing to use a
dollar on
and people aren't working then they have
very few dollars left
and they hold them very tightly because
all the money's being transferred to the
to the amazons that walt
you know walmart the blackrock etc
regular working-class people don't have
any money to spend right
so that means when you say i've got a
gallon of you know a gallon of water
would you like to buy it they go
i only got 10 bucks sorry i'm not
spending it i got to hold on to this
and then they go okay then how about for
five bucks no way dude
okay fine two bucks okay yeah that's not
going to happen no it's not going to
happen people value money over human
life
unfortunately that's the way the united
states is indebted
we still don't have the official tallies
from the federal reserve in their
printing but as of right
now 27.2 trillion dollars
that's an insurmountable amount that
can't be paid back
no matter what you do you could steal
the wealth of all the billionaires
and it won't even come close to running
the u.s government for one year
how much 27.4 trillion dollars it was
seven it was 27.2 yesterday how much of
that is
27.2 yesterday tim like how much of that
is compounded
interest do you know this out what the
principle is and how much of it is
interest
check this out from usdclock.org they
say
the u.s federal debt to gdp in in 1980
was 34
in 2000 was 55 and now it's
eight point 128.6 percent right sounds
like an inflection has been reached
yeah we are producing more debt than
goods that's what i'm saying
people aren't making things anymore and
they're cranking out money
to pay off debts they can't pay off buy
more germany dude
and then all of a sudden people don't
realize this it was in like the span of
one year
the the german mark went from like 20
marks to the dollar
to like was it like 200 billion yeah or
two yeah i think 200 billion marks to
dollar it was
just people shoveling money into
dumpsters that's the way the compound
interest works is it compounds on itself
it's like a j curve and then it just
goes straight up all of a sudden and
these people like alexandria
ocasio-cortez don't have any basic
understanding of
any math or logic or any common sense
because
if you look at her kind of larger plan
of tax to billionaires
if you would right now confiscate all
the wealth of
all the billionaires in the united
states you would still
not have enough money to run the us
government for one year
so people need to realize the amount of
debt the amount of money that this
government is spending is
absolutely insane i remember going down
to venezuela i remember going down to
zimbabwe
if you're lucky you might be able to
still find some my reports
i remember also going to india when they
had a currency reset
and seeing the actual pain that the
government caused people
by again just manipulating the financial
system in india they banned
particular rupee notes that uh
they just said didn't um matter anymore
so
so i landed in india and they literally
the next day had a currency reset
the government announced if you have
these very prominent bills
they don't matter anymore and they did
it because they wanted more people to
pay taxes because they knew a lot of
people were keeping their money either
in
uh shoeboxes in shoe boxes underneath
their bed
so after getting rid of all of these
bills the indian people literally just
had a few days to turn in all of their
money
to the government to the banks that of
course would keep a record
and tax them accordingly on it this is
why and then those notes were
became useless afterwards that's why
they love bitcoin
i don't know if they love bitcoin but
the us treasury department
wants to restrict your access to bitcoin
and you being able to transact in a way
that doesn't involve kyc
the big banks and they love it but they
want control of it
and they love it because it's the ledger
is public and they can see
everything you've bought transferred to
every single person
forever well you can't hyperinflate
bitcoin that's the thing there's a set
amount
that's true and you can't manipulate it
you can't print it out of thin air
and if you look at the dollar the dollar
is as strong as it is
mainly because of the us military
industrial complex and its
use of force all around the world to
make sure that the world
trades in the dollar now when the dollar
hyperinflates and when the dollar hits
the fan
this is not only going to affect the
united states this is going to affect
the entire world
and that's why i've been looking at
countries like chile that their currency
is not actually backed by the dollar
i've been looking at other kind of
alternatives as well but i think you
know we
we really need to start paying attention
to the alternatives out there because
i'm telling you i mean it's it's
insurmountable bro
i bought bitcoin a month ago i've i've
been periodically buying bitcoin
um not like crazy or anything like that
it's up uh
what 23 something thousand dollars and
i've
you know i i i'm i'm talking to you know
like you you
if you guys know max kaiser he's the
orange pill potty he's the one that told
me about bitcoin when it was still i
think a dollar
or a few cents and i told him to bug off
dude's a profit because i had to fight
the globalists
talking about the word super rich and
successful off of likes trading and
stocks and stuff he's a he's a financial
market guy
he's and you told him to screw up yeah
no when i was hanging out with max
and his buddy told me to buy square
stock i did and it's skyrocketed up to
like 200 you know like 2 000. i
own so much bitcoin and i'm still sad
when i see that it's up 27
in the last week you know it's really
just a sign that the dollar is failing i
sold 21 bitcoin in like 2012.
and i was excited and i remember i was
like what are you doing
not then another time no no not that
time another time you're
not that's not true that's not true i
sold once and i think i probably sold it
to you
hell maybe i think i sold it get rich
because it might or might not have
something
it skyrocketed up to 20 bucks and it was
this huge i think you didn't
actually donate bitcoin to tim
it was a couple hundred bucks i was like
dude like somebody just gave me i don't
care it's 400 bucks man i could pay my
rent i was like you want them and you're
like okay
here you go buddy yep yep now
so you think they're going to do a reset
loop that um they're going to be like
the reason
has already happened that's another
thing people need to realize the reset
is
now it's happening now john kerry was a
part of the biden administration
said it's going to come faster than
people realize
and it's definitely going to come under
the biden administration and we have to
remember
what's happening right now with the
destruction of small and independent
businesses with people being thrown into
poverty there's a new report
that says that 8 million people have
been thrown into poverty
since june the reset is here it's
happening and it's the largest transfer
of wealth in recorded human history that
looks like the radio have never been
richer than they are right now and
they're only going to become
more powerful than than ever there's
there's a
a threshold that i call it breaking the
barrier
that you make a certain amount of money
in your life you will never be poor
again
and so it's actually we're not talking
we're saying the rich people
i'm not talking about just jeff bezos
who's worth what like 180 billion or
whatever
i'm talking about people of a couple
mill that right now
if you've got money to float on for the
next couple of years
you're not going to be thrown into
poverty and unless you're sitting on
pure cash with no assets then i think
you're in trouble
because what they're going to do is
they're going to say u.s promises making
a good point here no look if dude if you
somehow talk about assets not money no
if you somehow came into a windfall of
cash randomly then sure fine but
any any regular person who's got a
couple million dollars
certainly has happened talking about
assets not just i'm talking not just
dollars
it's different the money is right right
but the reason that the reason that's
kind of a moot point is
you someone didn't just wake up and have
2 million dollars in cash that doesn't
happen so a lot of people are storing
cash right now i think what's going to
happen no they're not government
no regular government's going to be like
regular people's assets are tied up in
their homes
as it's always been equities in their
homes with the great depression people
that had buried cash in their backyard
ended up
being okay after the depression uh
because they were still at their cash
they couldn't get them out of the banks
so it's going to happen now the
government is going to recall the
federal reserve promissory notes
and they're going to start issuing new
dollars from the banks and all the
people are going to have to give their
promissory notes back and they'll have a
certain amount of time to do it and then
they'll get tagged that's what i said
happened yeah in which country
so which what is the indian the currency
reset yeah
the point i was making is that there are
people who are
not that rich but are rich and they're
sitting back right now at their feet up
as everything burns down around them
because what happens is
they go to the restaurants and they say
you can't open your restaurant anymore
and they say but dude
i've got like a three-month buffer too
bad six months goes by
and now their business is gone but
you've got a ton of people who work for
certain jobs that don't feel that
either they're insulated like it's a job
that is essential and can never go away
maybe a supermarket or something or it's
a walmart or something like that
and you have people who work certain
jobs day trading or some kind of
financial service
and they can just sit back and there are
certainly people who let's say they own
a bunch of chain restaurants maybe
there's a guy
who owns you know 50 i don't know little
caesars or wendy's's
well all of his employees are out of
work all of his managers are out of work
and they're all done
they can't pay their rent and they're
starving but this guy's got a net worth
of like 7 million
so he sits back and says we shut all the
buildings down we sold them off
i'm rich forever i got nothing to worry
about that's what the native american
chiefs did i mean just got bought off
look at bill gates bill gates 10 years
ago promised to donate all of his wealth
to charity
he had 53 billion dollars then
today after he said he was going to
donate all of his money he has 115
billion dollars you know why he said
that though when did he say that 2010
2010. you had all these ultra rich
people being like we're gonna we're
gonna do the right thing and and donate
our money why
we just had a massive economic collapse
and people were starting to yell
rabble rabble rabble and then we got and
then he announces things like this you
know we saw
after the 2008 financial crisis when
people were really mad and that
sentiment was bubbling up which
ultimately became occupy wall street
when people were like the fat cats are
super rich and so what happens with
warren buffett
remember when warren buffett was like we
gotta give our money away
it's not because they're like i know
deep down in my heart
it's because they're like if if if if it
hits the fan
they're coming to my house with
pitchforks so i remember when mark
zuckerberg announced he was giving his
money away
and they reported like mark zuckerberg
to donate all his money he was giving it
to an llc to hold to bypass the death
tax or the estate tax
and many people don't realize most
charities are utter scams and they're a
way for rich people just to launder
their money
and that's exactly what happens in many
instances not all of them of course
there are some good
charities there's some good ones like
the one that the bidens ran where
all all 99 95 of the money went to
salaries
or the clinton global initiative that
was a great charity endeavor that
jeffrey epstein even donated to a large
sum of money
but also you know the best investment
according to bill gates
the best investment according to bill
gates is of course vaccines which he
says you get a twenty to one return on
he said that he said that yeah hold on
hold on he isn't i did watch this
and he didn't say the best investment is
vaccines because of a 20
21. what he said was the best investment
has been in vaccine research because
i've saved many lives
he then later said i also got a 20 to 1
return on my investment yes that that
should be noteworthy that should just
question there but i appreciate the full
context right because you need
the full comments well the the reason
the reason i tell that context is
because the fact checks all say
false right and it's like false bill
gates did not say that
that's like a mathematical proof
when i pull up the the uh the actual
fact checks they're claiming what you
said isn't true
using a a false framing so when you know
what the actual truth is and say
yes he said the best investment was
helping people and save their lives and
i happen to have made a 21 return
that's the full context you can't fact
check that because that's the fact check
truth yup another thing to really think
about with this kind of financial
reckoning that's happening right now a
lot of people are talking about the
stock market's great the stock market is
strong
all of that is just artificially
inflated fake numbers and
just to kind of test it out i invested a
hundred dollars into the stock market in
september
and i also invested a hundred dollars
into bitcoin it's
in september so as far as my uh like
stock market
investment which was just kind of a
general exchange
i got a hundred a hundred dollars i'm
left with a hundred and
around twelve thirteen dollars with
bitcoin i already have two hundred and
four dollars
yeah but but here's what you gotta
understand about bitcoin's value
people don't get it of course they don't
let let me let me tell you something
very very simple
right now when people are dead set on
fiat currencies
the value of bitcoin is just a currency
protocol
meaning if i want to send someone money
very quickly i buy the bitcoin send it
to luke luke sells the bitcoin
us dollars to us dollars transacted
immediately using bitcoin as a form of
protocol
so i don't care what the value of
bitcoin is i just care that my
the immediate hundred dollar value
transfers to somebody who asked for it
and transfers out
lou gets a hundred dollars cash i get
100 cash and there's a small fee in
between
but the people who are trading on it and
buying more and more of it are
controlling that protocol which means
in the future as bitcoin becomes more
and more scarce people who want to use
it for its rapid transaction technology
are going to have to buy it from people
who are holding on to it
and saying only for you know ten
thousand dollars per coin they're like i
don't care
i'm i'm i'm buying it and then selling
it in 10 seconds
what do i care what you're selling it
for well that's why more and more people
are seeing it as a store of value
they're kind of seeing it as
gold and there's other cryptocurrencies
that they kind of use in order to have
these faster kind of transactions i
don't want to name any because i don't
want to be i was just thinking about the
same
thing can i say the craziest thing
anyone's ever said about bitcoin
go ahead yeah what is max kaiser saying
right now about the price of bitcoin do
you know
that it's going to go hyperbolic every
year from here 28.
i think this year i think he's saying
this year you know you know what i think
i don't have a timeline prediction but i
would not be surprised to see bitcoin at
a million bucks per coin
i'm not i'm not kidding and i'm not
saying in a year or two or three
i'm just saying if the weimar germany is
any you know
any historical impact on or what would
you say any reference to what's going on
yeah another thing you have to
understand i mean i mean buying power
right now it's relative to the dollar
i'm saying buying power i mean maybe
maybe the dollar goes
dollar goes down 10 000 bitcoin goes up
ten thousand percent just like in the
blink of an
eye because we're relating it to the
value i'm saying consider the buying
power of the dollar right now
and i would think a bitcoin at some
point would be comparable to a million
bucks
and the reason is because bitcoin can
only it's it's it's entropy
it's a scarce entity it's not just that
it can only be destroyed
so if people need to use bitcoin for
transactions
and it's the it has the most confidence
many look these other coins they come in
they go
then over the next several years we're
going to see a decreasing amount of
bitcoins
but an increase in the utility and the
and the need for it
more and more people will adopt it and
more and more people uh uh
and and less and less coins will exist
that means the only thing bitcoin can do
is go up
but people don't realize it you hear
these financial people saying things
like
it makes no sense that the price of
bitcoin is so high it doesn't you know i
don't understand
because they don't get it most people i
shouldn't say most people but a lot of
people who are transacting bitcoins
it's like i mentioned how can i get a
quick kick some quick cash to luke
i buy i go to the website i buy bitcoin
it transfers to luke it takes a few days
for you to get it though like if you go
to coinbase and buy it it takes if you
go through the kyc official
establishment
kind of which is but this is the crazy
thing about bitcoin
i could have a million dollars two
million dollars 10 million dollars all
in a passcode in my head and i could go
anywhere and open that wall at any time
that's without
anyone stopping me or taking it away
from me and that's
huge
it can't tax it of course with bitcoin
they could see all the transactions they
can see where imagine if
they're there they are taxing but monero
very much there are very vague and weird
rules about it that still have
it's just it's just an utter mess with
how the government's treating this
but more importantly bitcoin is the
first of its kind but there's other
coins out there privacy coins whether
monero or
that allow people to have their coins uh
privately
with them and privately transact with
them without a middle person being able
to see every little transaction like you
can with bitcoin
and another important aspect to really
understand here is that
bitcoin is the first of its kind it's
not perfect right but it shows you that
there is a new technological revolution
like the printing press
that is here that is right now that's
going to revolutionize how we transact
with each other
and there's a huge element of it trying
to make it a statist
corporatist government nightmare
that's going to track trace and database
you we have to understand there's a big
element of that
especially with venezuela russia and
other countries even the federal reserve
and these big banks talking about
creating their own coins
when they know every little thing about
you and then there's another big
battle happening right now with
individuals with
i think it's dash monero zcash and other
institutions that are trying to make it
more of a privacy
freedom liberty oriented technology that
will liberate and free people but
it could go either way and it could be a
tool that could enslave us or it could
be a tool that could
free us but right now that battle is
raging i know i know a lot of people who
are just
douche flutes that want to drive
lamborghinis and have little
e-girls surrounding them because they
made a bunch of money on the
but but and the market has been filled
with a lot of those
douche flutes but there's also another
element that that is very important
that came from the this kind of ron paul
liberty and the fed movement that is
still there that is still integral
that is still fighting for this basic
human right of
privacy that i think is extremely
important and
stop looking at the numbers stop looking
at the gains stop trying to get rich
look at the possibility here of actually
having a technology
that could be incredible for humanity
sure sure
yes but look at what's happening around
us when we look at the printing
of 35 percent of all us dollars in in 10
months
and you and and people are posting look
i brought this up
because i saw leftists bernie sanders
progressive socialist types
mocking capitalism and they were like
look at this it's going to be like
weimar germany
you know what else was like weimar
germany antifa in the streets
fighting with people on the right we see
the proud boys going out burning things
fighting people antifa
four proud boys apparently get stabbed
put in critical condition have to go to
the hospital
proud boy in uh i'm sorry not a problem
patriot prayer in portland gets two
bolts to the chest
i think you're right listen it's it's
extremely
destabilizing printing this money like
crazy
telling people they can't work and what
are we seeing right now in new york
they're saying
we're going into full lockdown new york
said full lockdown
indoor dining gone and how are they
doing
during the winter storm there were some
photos that came out that showed people
literally uh with a mask on full winter
gear on
just trying to eat in this huge snow
flurry could you imagine
like these insane government protocols
could you imagine like ordering
spaghetti
and like it comes out and it's a
blizzard and then you're sitting there
eating
and then after like five minutes it's
just an ice block and you're like
rising again as undercover new york city
police officers are walking around
trying to catch you to destroy you and
put you in jail
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm so come back to check us
out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you